[Musique]
ils ont fait un
bien énorme pour les gens de la classe ouvrière ici dans le
sud-ouest de la pennsylvanie,
les salaires, les conditions de travail ont
été
grandement améliorés grâce au
parti démocrate et aux syndicats
électriques ouais ouais
un démocrate bleu force
généralement les républicains étaient en  en faveur de
l'entreprise
et les démocrates étaient pro-syndicaux et en
faveur de la classe ouvrière
ce sont les entreprises pour lesquelles nous travaillons mon
père était vraiment
pour l'opprimé pour ainsi dire et vous
beaucoup on nous a appris ça au début
et c'était  Ce n'est pas deux ans plus tard, quand nous avons
démarré une entreprise et commencé à déménager,
euh que notre loyauté envers le
parti démocrate a
commencé à changer
la
capacité du plan politique,
tout est évincé à l'
étranger, toutes les entreprises et Trump
essaie de ramener ça bernadette
démocrate et tout est clair, Bill
Clinton
quelque chose juste  doit être fait et
et je ne le vois pas être fait de façon
décorative
t savoir cet
homme
il n'était pas bon avec ses femmes et ça
mais il a un chef d'entreprise il ne serait pas
là où il est s'il ne le faisait pas
l'homme est intelligent en 2016
euh ici quand trump est venu promis des emplois
pour se stabiliser  les mines de charbon et
pour inaugurer les tarifs de l'acier mais les emplois
ne sont pas
bien revenus mais il a essayé il a essayé nous avons la
délocalisation des emplois il a fait
valoir que je suis en faveur de cela
les démocrates étaient silencieux sur ce que les
américains veulent  dépensent leur argent de la
manière qui convient le mieux à leurs familles et pas
nécessairement à quoi le gouvernement choisit
de le dépenser
[Musique]
je veux que mes enfants n'aient jamais peur,
euh si c'est possible,
surtout en ces moments, j'ai l'impression que
ce n'est pas le cas
avec chaque
tirer c'est une raison de plus pour moi de
porter une arme à feu afin que je puisse
protéger ma famille
mademoiselle tracy sera là cheryl
les médias sociaux sont censés nous connecter
mais ils font
un très bon travail pour nous déconnecter
comment réagissez-vous quand  vous en voyez
tweets
du président euh honnêtement j'aimerais que
quelqu'un lui dise d'arrêter de tweeter
je pense qu'il porte la responsabilité japan
trump assa
[Music]
ouais j'aimerais changer la
rancœur partisane j'aimerais faire ma part
pour rassembler la communauté
communautaire  et faire des choses
j'aimerais que notre économie soit à
nouveau en bonne santé
je voterais pour ce gars est
d'être pro-vie est d'être pro-femme et d'
être pro-bébé
et donc son plaidoyer et
sa présence réelle à  la marche pour la
vie
ses euh votes et ses recommandations pour
la cour suprême
me font voter pour lui combien d'
employés aviez-vous
environ deux ou trois cents oh oui nous avons
travaillé dans tout le pays
[Musique]
csx l'un de nos
travaux ferroviaires est le nom  du jeu ici, les gens
ont travaillé, ils ont travaillé dans des mines de charbon
qui travaillaient dans des aciéries
et ils sont tout à fait contre tout type
de bien-être,
alors tout d'un coup, le gars qui était un
col bleu démocrate
euh 20 ans plus tôt devient maintenant un
porteur de carte  républicain